the mummy when you've got as much clout
as tom cruise you can make all sorts of
stipulations when you sign on for a
movie
reportedly cruz's demands for the 2017
mummy movie
included near total creative control as
later outlined in a variety
investigation cruz was accused of
micromanaging almost every aspect of the
film's production
changing everything from the script to
the way it was marketed perhaps most
notably cruz allegedly insisted that his
character nick morton be given more
screen time than the mummy his presence
was beefed up accordingly effectively
turning the horror franchise reboot into
another of the star's blockbuster action
vehicles
snakes on a plane just like snakes have
all sorts of reasons for getting on
planes
stars have all sorts of reasons for
agreeing to take on a role
samuel l jackson for example admitted
that he only wanted to star in snakes on
a plane because of its title when
executives considered changing the title
to pacific flight 121
he personally intervened telling them it
was the stupidest damn thing i ever
heard
jackson also advocated for more violence
and profanity in issue because the
studio envisioned snakes as a campy
pg-13 action movie
eventually they agreed with his more
adult-oriented take and he agreed to
reshoots to secure an r rating which
just served to make the edited tv
version all the more ridiculous i have
had it with these monkey fighting snakes
on this monday to friday play the
avengers
in the original script for the avengers
the scene immediately following the near
defeat of the chitauri
was much less lighthearted after sending
the bomb through the wormhole and
falling back to earth tony stark simply
asked what's next
after being roused by his comrades
robert downey jr felt this line fell a
little flat and suggested trying
something different
according to entertainment weekly
director joss whedon put together three
pages of new lines based on downey's
suggestions
in the newly revamped scene iron man has
a little more banter with his teammates
you ever tried shwarma there's a
shawarma joint about two blocks from
here
i don't know what it is but i want to
try it everyone liked the line so much
that whedon filmed a bonus post-credits
scene of the entire cast eating
but since production had already wrapped
he had to film the scene when the cast
came back together for the premiere
according to ew chris evans even had to
wear a fake jaw prosthetic to hide the
beard he'd grown
that's why captain america isn't eating
with the rest of the team and it was all
because robert downey jr wanted to spice
up his lines
jurassic world critics were pretty happy
with jurassic world but that didn't stop
audiences from complaining that bryce
dallas howard's character somehow
outruns 22 tons of t-rex in high heels
director colin trevorrow was completely
aware of how ridiculous this was
and reportedly spent much of the film's
production trying to convince her
to literally slip into something more
comfortable howard refused insisting
that her character had to wear heels the
whole time
your last two minutes in there less than
those ridiculous shoes
trevorrow would later admit that he
wasn't exactly sure why howard was so
insistent but he respected her decision
and the heels stayed in
howard herself would later say she never
expected wearing the heels to be such a
major talking point but she was happy to
have the effort she put into running
through the jungle acknowledged
noting that no camera trickery was used
she really did wear the shoes in every
scene
clash of the titans bubo the clockwork
owl is one of the most memorable parts
of the original clash of the titans so
naturally
director louis laterier planned on
making it a major part of his 2010
remake
unfortunately sam worthington hated bubo
the terrier later recounted that
worthington complained about the owl at
every opportunity going as far as to
accuse the director of trying to ruin
his career by making him star
opposite something so ridiculous
letterier goaded worthington by saying
he wasn't trying to ruin his career
just damage it which didn't exactly help
matters
ultimately to appease his star leteriae
took the owl out of the film
relegating it to a brief cameo shrek
shrek's signature scottish accent went
through a couple of major changes before
audiences fell in love with the big
green ogre
saturday night live vet chris farley was
originally supposed to voice the
character but passed away before he
could finish recording his lines
after his passing mike myers stepped in
it wasn't until after roughly a third of
the movie had been animated however that
myers decided shrek should be scottish
meyer's reasoning was that since the
movie's villain lord farquaad spoke with
an upper class english accent shrek
should sound more blue-collar
to highlight the difference between them
it's
hideous oh that's not very nice
it's just a donkey he also felt that the
scottish accent lent itself better to
dramatic abrupt shifts in tone and would
allow him to emote in a more exaggerated
fashion
dreamworks exec jeffrey katzenberg
pegged the cost of reworking the already
animated scenes at four to five million
dollars
roughly 10 percent of the movie's
overall budget star wars attack of the
clones
after watching a rough cut of the battle
for geonosis with star wars creator
george lucas
samuel l jackson noticed it was hard to
spot his own character mace windu
amongst the dozens of jedi on screen
he asked lucas if it would be possible
for windu to wield a purple lightsaber
partly because it did stand out more and
partly because purple is jackson's
favorite color
i said to george you think maybe i can
get a purple lightsaber
lightsabers are green and lightsabers
are in them yeah but i want a purple one
lucas initially turned down the request
but later decided to let jackson get his
purple lightsaber
because when samuel l jackson asks for
something he gets it
i have the real one at home that has bad
right here
a million ways to die in the west family
guy has mocked a lot of people over the
years but one joke in particular came
back to haunt creator seth macfarlane
family guy made a joke about how liam
neeson would never be able to play a
cowboy in a western because of his
inability to convincingly mask his
distinctive irish accent
this glen's gonna be tough to traverse
and that river's got to be 50
60 meters wide and god knows how many
fathoms
years later when mcfarland asked liam
neeson to star in his comedy western a
million ways to die in the west
neeson said he'd do it with one
condition when seth called me up to
ask would i do this film i said i'll do
it on condition that i can use
my own irish accent mcfarlane agreed and
neeson's character became an
inexplicably irish cowboy
all because of a throwaway line in an
old episode of family guy suggesting
that it'd be pretty stupid for anyone to
hire liam neeson to star in western
you really do have a death waste don't
you thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
please check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love too